that's why it's incredible  by someone so unforgettable thinks that  I am  that's how the Grammys paid tribute to  the late Natalie Cole Monday night and  it did not go over well with Natalie's  sisters who spoke exclusively to et  after the show quote sadly a forgettable  tribute to Natalie Cole words cannot  express the outrage and utter  disappointment at the disrespectful  tribute or lack thereof to a legendary  artist such as our sister Timlin and  casey cole noted Natalie's 21 and Grammy  nominations and nine Grammy wins saying  she deserved more than just a mention in  the in memoriam segment quote it was  shameless the way they minimized her  legacy we will find a solace in her  legacy as well as her endless fans  around the world